we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a question from
a viewer about something former Fox News
host Bill O'Reilly recently said
hey David it's James again
um I don't know if you heard but Bill
O'Reilly recently made this prediction
that uh Joe Biden is going to announce
uh that he will resign after the
midterms
um
I I think that at the most he'll
announce that he won't run again but he
won't announce it over to dying uh just
less than two years into his uh term
um my question to you is do you think
Bill O'Reilly actually believes that or
is he lying in sort of pan right to an
audience because he figures like his
audience would love to hear that Biden's
gonna resign
or do you think that there's any truth
to that
um
I certainly don't yeah so listen what
the caller is referring to is that on
news Nation Bill O'Reilly showed up and
everything Bill O'Reilly says he says
very confidently Bill O'Reilly said that
sometime after the midterms Joe Biden is
going to announce I'm resigning the
presidency and it's because of health
reasons and Bill O'Reilly went on to say
Kamala Harris is not going to be a
viable candidate for 2024 so it's going
to leave Democrats in a difficult
position in 2024.
um listen I don't have any reason right
now to think that Joe Biden is going to
resign the thing about Bill O'Reilly is
he'll tell you whatever and he'll say it
extraordinarily confidently his
confidence should not be used to
evaluate the likelihood of the claim is
it conceivable that a president would
resign yes sometimes presidents resign
uncommon but it can happen it is a
mechanism that exists
all else being equal is it more likely
that the older a president is the more
likely it is they might resign for
health reasons I think statistically
that's probably true I think it's more
likely an 80 year old president would
resign for health reasons than a 70 year
old president than a 60 year old
president then a 50 for you get the
point
do I have any reason to believe that
this is part of Biden's plan not at all
and it's increasingly looking to me like
Joe Biden does want to run for
reelection in 2024 six months ago I
would not have said that but it
increasingly looks that way and I do
agree with the caller that if there's
going to be a sort of a wind down to
Biden's presidency that will not include
four more years it will be Biden saying
I'm not running for re-election is a
resignation possible of course it's
possible
um but I I don't have any particular
reason to think that's the plan we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk more about Elon Musk Elon Musk
uh wasting no time after buying Twitter
in instituting some changes not all of
them particularly exciting uh secondly
men exonerated in the killing of Malcolm
X are set to receive 36 million dollars
it's an incredible case which we will
talk about and we are going to talk
about ballot measures up next Tuesday
it's it's election day next Tuesday can
you believe it measures that could
change how Americans vote
how Americans Gamble and how Americans
Vote many uh how Americans smoke rather
many changes potentially coming on
smoking gambling and voting to multiple
States we will talk about those ballot
initiatives and much more on today's
bonus show when I am joined by producer
Pat remember to get instant access to
the bonus show you go to joinpakman.com
and you sign up there's a big red sign
up button it's easy it's quick I believe
the normal prices for membership are so
reasonable but I understand sometimes a
discount is appealing you can use the
coupon code big voting 22 to get
yourself that discount and remember if
you watch us on YouTube and you're not
subscribed help us get to 2 million
subscribers it's free hit that subscribe
button I will see you on the bonus show
or otherwise we will be back tomorrow
with our one week out from the midterms
program